when you found out that the FBI had
located even more classified materials
in Wilmington which four-letter word did
you use
[Music]
makers of the internet what will you
people come up with next I'm Dave Rubin
this is the Reuben report it's January
24th 2023 we are live streaming on
Rumble YouTube and locals but
particularly on Rumble and locals
because that is going to be what much of
the framing of today's show is all about
and as you guys know we now do a
post-game wrap-up show every day locals
exclusive which if you want to join us
and you can correct me you can comment
on the show you can throw questions at
me you can noodle me whatever you would
like to do noodle me that sounded weird
uh you can go to reubenreport.locals.com
the theme today is going to be very much
about the tech situation and how it is
connected to so much of what we've been
talking about lately with the wef and
all the woke nonsense and and the usual
stuff so whether it's Tech censorship
wokeness World economic Forum
centralization media manipulation all of
these things come bind and this is my
this is my thesis for today when you
combine all of these things it's very
understandable how we've led up to this
real General state of confusion that
most people seem to be in right now and
of course this is directly connected to
what's happening to us politically where
yesterday's liberals actual liberals
seem to be today's conservatives
conservatives seem to be defending
old-school liberalism everything sort of
seems upside down and there's a lot of
weirdness out there but what I want to
first start with because this is why we
decided to do the show the way we're
going to do it today is that you might
find it interesting that yesterday's
live stream which I think has around 150
000 views on on YouTube a ton of views
on Rumble it was demonetized by YouTube
so first let's show you the image so
this is this is a screenshot of my phone
and I'm not showing you this to cry what
was me or ask anyone for money or
anything like that I just want to show
you how there is a type of censorship a
soft censorship related to
demonetization and how it's connected to
the world economic forum and we got
video receipts to prove it so what
you're seeing there is a screenshot of
my phone that's in the YouTube Creator
studio and what they show you there
because yesterday we went after Queen
Greta thundberg and we also showed that
video from Pfizer where the Pfizer CEO
Albert borla was being questioned by
Ezra Levant about how the vaccines are
not working and you can see what they
did there they placed our video on
limited monetization which once you get
the limited thing that little yellow
dollar sign you're seeing there if you
read some of the text there uh you'll
you're going to earn limited to no ad
Revenue in essence you get no ad Revenue
like you might earn six bucks something
like that so in essence there's really
no money to be made there now of course
now first off there's a whole bunch of
things here and I promise you this is
not a plea for money this is not a uh a
gin and up support this is to show you
how these things things are connected
not that there's anything wrong with
with trying to make money too because I
also have a capitalist but I'm just
putting that out there on just to be
said there's a soft type of censorship
right we think of censorship as oh you
say something and then they blow up your
account or they suspend you or something
else but there's a more nefarious in the
world we live in now with so many
creators out there saying what they
think for a living
um and often doing a much better job
than mainstream media there's a more
nefarious censorship which is the the
demonetization censorship or the shadow
Banning so Shadow Banning as you guys
know it's like you put your stuff out
there you think you have a certain
amount of followers and a certain set of
people just don't see it the machine
decides to not let a certain amount of
people see it the demonetization
censorship I think is probably the most
Twisted one because it creates a system
of selective pressures for those of us
that are trying to say something true if
you're just all day long putting up
click bait and nonsense and playing into
the machine and giving the machine what
it wants and all of those things you're
going to get an awful lot of views and
then those views come with dollars
because of the advertisers but let's say
you start saying something true let's
say you start making fun of Greta
thundberg who's worthy of being made fun
of or you go after the wef people or you
complain about our politics here or
whatever whatever the thing might be it
doesn't even matter what is it may not
even always be political
but let's say you do that and then you
start realizing that your videos are
getting demonetized well most people
that do something like this for a living
you want to create a life for yourself
you'd like to make some money while
doing it right it's not it's not just
purely just to exist it's that you're
trying to actually build a functioning
business which I've actually done quite
well and I'm very proud of that so what
they can do though is if they see that
you're going in a certain direction they
can just demonetize you and what you
might do is go boy you know I'm putting
a lot of work and effort into this I've
built a company and I've hired people we
put a lot of work into all of this and
the more work that we do even though
it's good and true and honest we're not
making money so we're actually starting
to lose money because you got to put
money in to build make something in the
first place right just doing this right
now with the pipes that we're doing I
don't know what Connor's doing over
there but we have a computer somebody
paid for that you know what I mean it
costs certain amount of money so the
point is when they demonetize it's not
just about the dollars it's about their
the way that that they can send the
signal to you that you should censor
yourself so now watch How I link this
through basically everything happening
all over the world a whole bunch of
people are waking up to it one of the
guys that's waking up to it is the
biggest podcaster on planet Earth and
probably several other planets as well
Joe Rogan you may remember that Joe
Rogan at one time he's had the biggest
podcast in the world for about a decade
I mean his numbers are like Beyond
through the roof it's one of the reasons
that mainstream media is always trying
to take him out it's not because he's
really saying anything dangerous this is
a this is an old school liberal sort of
libertarian MMA mushroom eating pot
smoking you know workout doing dude who
likes to eat smoked meat okay he's not
some scary right wing or whatever that
means but the machine is always trying
to take him out because he's getting
more views than the machines they're
trying to take out the competition this
is Mafia 101. Joe Rogan has realized how
dangerous this situation is related to
YouTube uh here he is with comedian who
is this Tim what's his name Tim Dillon
talking about what's going on over at
YouTube
what's going to happen is there'll be
places where people are going to say
that like I do I do think that what's
gonna happen YouTube is this big big
platform right but I I do think you have
other platforms like Rumble and like
Odyssey and they're just never going to
be as big as YouTube but I think you
know rumble's got what 60 million people
on there it's not small no rumble's
really growing they're growing huge and
so they're signing people too they're
signing people to go over to rumble
which makes sense yeah okay so there you
have the world's biggest podcaster
engaging in a conversation and he's done
this many times about how YouTube is
censoring people and then that creates
an opportunity I would like to believe
as Joe was talking about there that
Rumble at locals are the answer to that
opportunity meaning if YouTube is going
to censor everybody there could be a
place where independent people to say
what they wish without being censored
with a fair advertising system and
everything else but now I want to show
you how the how the machine reacts to
people who fight the power uh one of the
guys who is just one of the ones given
the machine what they want all the time
this is something that I often talk
about with the late night TV host you
know this is the Colbert Jimmy Kimmel
thing they just say whatever the machine
wants the machine wants them to put on a
hat and do a ridiculous dance talking
about vaccines they'll do that they'll
do anything to suck off the machine
another guy like that is Trevor Noah
Trevor Noah of course took over The
Daily Show from Jon Stewart it was it
was crushing it in numbers the thing
that everyone always said about The
Daily Show was this is where more young
people get their news from The Daily
Show than anywhere else I never really
found that to be true or whatever but
that was the meme about The Daily Show
but obviously it was a cultural icon
whether you liked it or not when Jon
Stewart had it they gave it to Trevor
Noah he basically turned it into a
leftist trash bin but now watch his
reaction you may remember a couple
months back boy time has flown it's
about six or eight months ago already
when Joe Rogan was on the verge of being
canceled by Spotify because a bunch of
people found old videos where he said
the N word right and he never said it
like you're an n-word he didn't say it
to be pejorative or mean or racist or
bigoted he was saying it often to mock
the people who say it or quoting a
rapper or something to that effect and
they tried to cancel him CNN was trying
to cancel him Spotify was under pressure
the Bots and the trolls were saying
we're going to cancel Spotify all this
stuff and watch Trevor Noah's take on
this this is as the whole thing was
unfolding even a society where we cost
people out because the the the like as
you say the bad people are so happy for
that they're so they like like there was
that um it's like another streaming
platform or whatever it is they offered
Joe Rogan money and I don't know if they
would give it to him or not but they
said come Joe and bring all those n-word
podcasts with you do you know what I
mean and I was going like yo do I do I
want to live in a world where someone
like Joe Rogan doesn't get a chance
and becomes welcomed by the worst of
society or do I want to live in a world
where Joe Rogan can say yeah I up
and yeah I was being full of and
yeah I was playing with racism and I
up and and and now I don't want
to be a part of that okay so first off
Trevor no he there's like a lot of
double speaking there so it's hard to
make sense of what he's actually trying
to say I'm not really sure which world
he wants to live in Trevor Noah has also
before he became the uh the host of The
Daily Show which he no longer is anymore
does the show even exist did they get
anyone nobody knows it doesn't matter
um he had all sorts of Politically
Incorrect jokes like like wildly
offensive jokes to certain people right
but no one cares to die all right say
your stupid jokes dude I don't care uh
by the way the the company that he's
talking about he's talking about Rumble
of course he knows it's Rumble and the
offer that he's talking about was the
hundred million dollar offer that Rumble
made to Joe Rogan and I can tell you as
the guy that it was my idea and who
wrote the actual offer that was sent to
Joe Rogan it 100 was legit and I think
it will come to fruition one day that
we'll probably have to pay him a whole
bunch more but is what it is but the
point is you see the reaction to a guy
like that like the implication by Trevor
Noah is Joe Rogan is a racist and there
are these companies that want to take
him and his n-word podcasts and just
distribute them to a whole bunch of
scary mean white supremacist type people
and it's like no that's not really what
any of this was but you are giving the
system whatever the system wants and
what I think the beautiful thing about
this is Joe Rogan is waking up the
people that watch his show are waking up
you guys are waking up as I've been
saying as scary as all of the messaging
from the wef has been a whole bunch of
people are waking up to it the video is
destroying the wef are getting far more
views than the videos promoting the Waf
if you look at the the wf's YouTube page
I mean imagine these guys are in cahoots
with YouTube look at their YouTube page
their videos get like 4 000 views so
they don't represent any individual they
just represent a bad set of ideas but
speaking of a bad set of ideas one of
the uh one of the Liberals that you know
I'm always working on is disaffected
liberal but still self-proclaimed
liberal uh Bill Maher Bill Mars
struggling with his own team because
they not no longer believe in diversity
of thought and Bill Maher recently was
talking about where that rot comes from
and I think he nailed it I really think
look we we are I think when historians
look back at our time they will not
divide us into red and blue and
Republican Democrat and like the things
that were wrong with us were wrong with
both sides in different ways I do think
they manifest in a more dangerous way on
the right but on the left there is a rot
and it comes from Academia and I agree
and it filters down am I am I wrong
about that that's where it's all coming
from I just think this is an epitome of
it is what the mother says and then the
kid robbed your money
it's quite true the place in American
society really all Western Society where
the the horrific ideas of leftism and
wokeism and collectivism socialism these
top-down ideas these ideas that are
anti-human Liberty they're anti the
individual because they don't want you
thinking for yourself they want to think
for you these have all taken root at
universities uh throughout this country
and as I said throughout the world so he
is getting it on that point they will
scream
till their heads explode about diversity
but of course as you guys know the one
diversity that they hate is diversity of
thought and this is something that I
think a whole bunch of people did not we
we just thought the thing was going to
work we just thought oh you could send
your kid to a school to get a degree in
lesbian badminton and whatever it might
be and you'll spend a lot of money doing
it but the machine will just keep
working and they'll just get a job and
everything will be okay but now after
probably four Decades of this
indoctrination we are seeing the fruits
of that and you have to give credit to
the Socialists you have to give credit
to all of these people who said we will
start at the schools and we will
indoctrinate Youth and does that sound a
little something similar to what's going
on with all these uh trans drag shows or
or drag queen drag shows kid drag shows
whatever the hell's going on over there
like you get them young you confuse them
with bad ideas young you show a
six-year-old a dude in a dress dancing
around saying crazy things and it's not
it's just to confuse them because a
confused mind is is fertile ground to a
to a soul a stolen rest of your life
something like that uh anyway even Bill
Maher as he has come around on all this
stuff he's still not voting Republican
right he's not quite getting there on
that but he is addressing the problems
and there is value in someone on that
side of the aisle who some of these
people will still listen to because
although many of them are brainwashed
there are still some good people out
there and we can shift them uh he has
been talking about how if they ever come
back with mandates that uh he is not
going to let them deal with his own
personal health
I do not want to be dictated there is no
the science
especially in medical science you can
recommend whatever you like but I must
insist you don't insist how I handle my
health
I never was yes okay no Obama Obama told
me if you like your doctor you can keep
your doctor well I did and I do
and my doctors I know many of them say
very different things because doctors
are afraid to speak out
okay so now I want to show you how I'm
linking this to where we started at the
show today so we started at the show
today with me showing you that we did a
live stream yesterday talking about
Greta thundberg and talking about Albert
borla the Pfizer CEO and exposing these
people for the frauds that they are
right we then got demonetized by YouTube
so a guy like me could go maybe I don't
want to hit those topics again you know
what I mean like I want to make as much
money as possible I want to grow my
company do the things that I want to do
with my family and my life okay uh I'm
not going to stop because we've built
the right pipes right here to keep going
but now I want to show you how that is
connected to what we just talked about
because when Bill Maher is talking about
I don't want to be coerced well a year
ago if you talked about medical coercion
on YouTube you would be demonetized if
you talked about how perhaps mutilating
the genitals of children was a bad idea
you might be be demonetized and these
ideas are all coming from somewhere so
now get this this is video just from the
last couple days in the world economic
Forum here is a guy by the name of
Richard Edelman he is the CEO of the
world's largest public relations firm
known as Edelman and here he is telling
businesses to deprive social media
platforms of money if they spread
disinformation
so I think the first thing that um
because I mostly work with business that
business needs to do is
deprive
platforms that spread disinformation of
oxygen
stop advertising
pull your promotion money make sure that
they understand that they have a
consequential impact on society and the
boycott of Twitter for several months
has had
a modest modest impact but I think
the Facebook one failed
and but the necessity of getting it
right in the platforms that are probably
primary source information for
about third to 40 of people is urgent
all right you guys are wise so I think
you can see what I'm doing here that is
the CEO of the most powerful public
relations firm on Earth at this
globalist conference telling them to go
home and tell your companies not to
advertise on certain platforms for
misinformation now it's interesting I
don't think he's talking about CNN even
though CNN has spread the Russia hoax
and Jesse Smith and Kavanaugh is a
rapist and Kyle writtenhouse is a white
supremacist and the list goes on and on
and on you guys get it okay fine but it
continued at the world economic Forum uh
here is video of European Union
commissioner Vera girova explaining how
Twitter and Elon must comply must comply
that is very scary must
our message was clear we have the rules
which has to which have to be complied
with and otherwise there will be
sanctions
[Music]
I think that the confidence has been
weakened
and I I had quite a high level of
confidence when it comes to Twitter I
have to say that we worked with
knowledgeable people with the lawyers
with the sociologists who understood
that they have to
behave in some decent way not to cause
really big harm to the society I always
felt that this this notion of
responsibility was there so this is what
I don't feel from uh Elon Musk
personally
it's rather extraordinary I mean when
these people when they say something
everything that they say is the reverse
of the truth that's like the Trudeau
Gavin Newsom situation everything they
say just listen to what they say and
assume that the reverse is true she
wants Twitter to behave responsibly well
Twitter was silencing the hunter Biden
laptop and Twitter was hiding uh the
covid Skeptics by Shadow Banning and
banning people outright and suspending
accounts and all of those things so you
see how this is connected to where I
started today let's show that image
again do you think that there might be
something going on there the world
economic forum is meeting they're very
angry at Twitter because elon's letting
people talk but they're also bringing on
big powerful PR people to tell companies
make sure you don't send money to things
that aren't in line with us and then
some little crazy guy some real nut bag
with a lot of hairspray in Miami Florida
says I will keep going despite what you
lizard people demand
and that's where we're at with this
thing but it is not just information
that they are trying to control you know
this they are trying to control every
facet of your life they want to control
your language they want to control your
thought they want to control your
medical decisions and now is because is
becoming more and more obvious and this
might be the top one for them they want
to control your energy uh here let's go
back to Davos and the fine work once
again of Ezreal event and the theme over
at Rebel news who are just doing
absolute bang-up job over there here
they are questioning John Kerry and you
remember John Kerry he's our is he still
is he considered our climate Czar is
that his title I think the man is our
climate Czar which is complete orwellian
drivel uh this is a guy who flies
private all over the place as I said on
the show a few days ago he married
Teresa Hines so he married into big
ketchup money okay he's very very rich
there is no doubt he has several gas
stoves and he has his private chefs and
he has his private planes and multiple
houses and he also looks like a tree
from Lord of the Rings what's the name
of the tree again Enoch and he looks
like Enochs his ENT all the trees or is
there a specific tree named ants
ant is the type of tree okay good to
know he looks like an ant from Lord of
the Rings half man half tree here's John
Kerry being questioned by the good guys
over at Rebel
secretary Kerry do you think that the
high price of natural gas is actually a
helpful thing to get people to
transition to a green economy I'd love
to talk about it but I just can't do it
on the Run Justified being here yourself
take private jets can you answer that
but you're taking a private jet before
you know but you're taking the project
forward to collect the climate climate
change Awards you have done that I fly
commercial exclusive
hey why commercial exclusively this is
such a lie they lie
about everything and I am not begrudging
them their private fights they're
begrudging you your modes of
transportation if you're rich and you
got a plane that's awesome I'll say it
right here I would love to be rich
enough one day so that I could have a
plane and only fly private it would be
wonderful flying commercial is a
nightmare people are not good anymore
that's a thing it was much much worse
under covid people have gotten a little
bit better but everything being equal
would you guys like to fly private or
commercial for now on when we do Reuben
report Adventures
private everybody wants private okay
well yeah they're just trying to kill
the environment over here uh but he's a
liar and a fraud and good work by Rebel
of course uh but here let's continue
because they want to control energy
think about it once they can control
energy like it's one thing you can
control information and you can get
people to believe a lot of bad things
but then if you can get people if you
can control energy and you can get
people not to go outside as much not to
eat this or that as much not to do
certain things they want to control
every facet of your life so here is
video of Biden Energy Secretary Jennifer
granholm and here she is trying to sell
incentives to get us off gas stoves and
I normally don't lead a clip like this
but I'll just say fat chance lady
let's talk about stoves because the big
energy story over the last couple weeks
has been uh my gas stove I'm a gas stove
owner can I say that is so ridiculous
that story because okay well it's like
government's coming in to take your
stuff that is so not true that is just
not true and In fairness the science on
this is well established there's nothing
new here about the health risks posed by
gas stoves and as I did a little poking
around I discovered that the government
right now is Department of energy you
want to Electrify your buildings yes and
remove natural gas as a fossil fuel
right first off let me just deal with
that quote-unquote journalist I don't
know who he is I suspect I'll never play
another clip of him but he is an
absolute Total Tool he starts the
segment by saying that he has a gas
stove and then a moment later he says
the science is well established on this
meaning the health risks about having a
gas stove so is he an effing idiot
dude you're killing yourself but I know
I know you just like to it's nice to
saute you know you want that Golden
Crisp on your chicken fingers you gotta
have that gas stove because on electric
it's hard to get that crisp hard to
manipulate
God these people are awful okay so
Jennifer Grant home real quick Jennifer
granholm if you don't remember her she
was one of the hosts remember I told you
guys the other day that Al Gore had a
television station after he became vice
president uh he used his connections as
vice president to get a television
station that he created it was called
current TV it was an utter failure
nobody watched it but he got it on all
these cable channels because he
leveraged his power as vice president to
do that because if you want to create a
cable channel the real thing is getting
on the Cable Systems getting on Comcast
getting on DirecTV et cetera et cetera
so he used his power that he had his VP
to do that he creates a failure of a
channel nobody was advertising on it
nobody was watching it and then he ends
up selling it for 500 million dollars to
the government of Qatar he sold it it
became Al Jazeera America which then
folded Glenn Beck tried to buy it but he
would have rather sold it to the number
two exporter of oil than to scary
right-wing Glenn Beck how am I relating
this to watching that woman she was a
host on that Network interestingly
Jennifer granholm was uh when she tells
you that this is a ridiculous story and
they're not coming for her stove you
must understand this is not a ridiculous
story and they are coming for your stove
and it's partly because of tools just
utter tools like that quote-unquote
journalist who sits down with her admits
he has an electric stove says he knows
the signs on it he never talked about
the signs I have no doubt no doubt if
you went to ever I don't know who this
guy is it does not even matter but if
you look at the entire catalog of his
life's work he's never been concerned
about gas stoves before but the machine
sends a signal and all the NPCs go okay
I don't like gas stoves either not going
to get rid of my gas stove but okay
uh here's Grant Jennifer granholm
talking about how it's the Republicans
they're screwing everything up he will
not allow the American people to suffer
because of the backwards agenda that
House Republicans are advancing
it's interesting lady because until uh
what was it about uh well about 23 days
ago or so it was the Democrats were in
charge the whole freaking thing uh now
she's very concerned that the
Republicans the mean Republicans are
going to destroy everything however it's
been the Democrats in charge who tanked
the economy and got us into the war
non-war in Ukraine and wrecked the
border and a whole bunch of other stuff
but what else how is this all connected
the censorship what the censorship
whether it's outright silencing you or
whether it's demonetizing you changing
the way you think whether it's deciding
what you can cook on and what you can
drive and again none of these are things
that they will incorporate into their
own lives it's always about control of
you whether it's speech or medical
health we talked about the covid part of
this energy it all boils down to the
next thing that they're going after and
this is going to be a bigger and bigger
one yeah you got it it's the second
amendment they are going to try to come
for your guns the same way that they are
coming for gas stoves this is not a
crazy conspiracy theory I don't need to
scream it like Al Gore screams
everything he doesn't he's lying about
everything so he needs to emote in a
crazy way I'm just telling you how it is
and I think you all know it they want
your guns right so as you guys know
there was the uh well as you probably
know there was another shooting there
were two shootings in California over
the last week or so and Gavin Newsom you
know you never let a crisis go to waste
Gavin Newsom who I believe is a lizard
person people often say to me Dave what
do you mean he's a you think he's a
lizard wearing a human skin that's crazy
and and yes I believe that I've now come
to believe that he is a lizard person
sent here from another planet to ruin
San Francisco ruin California and his
ultimate goal is to ruin the United
States and I will not allow the lizard
person to do it and at the end of the
movie you know the White House is
burning and there I am and you know my
hair this way and and I rip his face off
and I see the lizard person and then
he's laughing
because he set off a bomb that he has on
his arm like a nuclear bomb and then I
have to wait I'm doing Predator that was
in Predator but okay the point of this
is Newsome's a bad dude number one he
wants your guns number two
I mean the second amendment's becoming a
Suicide pack it feels like it's just uh
and that's the only question the
community wants so how do you get it
what about our kids when they're going
to school
what more can we do and you know yeah we
look at that all the time I'm mad
doesn't
gun safety bills last year will continue
to find whatever loopholes we can we
continue to lead the national
conversation on gun safety reform and
the data Bears out it works it saves
lives California's 37 lower gun death
rate for the rest of the nation and yet
with all that evidence no one on the
other side seems to give a damn they
can't get anything about your powers
yeah
I know you all noticed this but Evil
Lizard Man there he had four armed
security guards there is no doubt 100
certainty those are armed security
guards as he has to walk around the
of whatever city that is I
don't even know what city that was do we
know it even that was La so he was in LA
oh so it was a literal
um he has to walk around La with forearm
security guards because he doesn't want
to get accosted he doesn't want to get
shot he doesn't want to get spit on or
injected with fentanyl I would assume
there's crazy people running around just
injecting people with fentanyl probably
running the Democrat party over there so
what he wants to do even though these
shootings are never these shootings are
never I don't know that there's been one
mass shooting in the history of the
United States that was ever done by a
member of the NRA there have been
several moments where good guys with
guns have stopped people that are doing
mass shootings and it turns out that the
good guy who has proper training with
firearms and everything else stops the
guy but what he wants to do is he
believes that there is violence and the
only way that you stop violence is you
stop people from being able to protect
themselves it is a mental disorder that
only an authoritarian lizard person
could possibly have but ladies and
Gentlemen even in dystopian Los Angeles
a place that is like adjacent to Hell
there are a couple good people left
Phoenix was like it's true it's true
it's adjacent to hell
um there are a couple good people left
uh so in the aftermath of one of these
last two shootings here is L.A County
Sheriff Robert Luna
talking about how California has every
gun law known to man and perhaps it's
not about more laws gun violence needs
to stop there's too much of it we're all
standing here tonight because uh an
individual
took a weapon and did the damage that
we've talked about without repeating it
I think
all of us uh
need to take some ownership there I
think we really need to go back and look
at what we do
uh California has some of the strictest
gun laws in the country but yet look
what we just had today
so let's look at across our nation see
what works and what doesn't
but I could tell you this the status
quo's not working
okay so note he didn't call for new gun
laws he acknowledges that California has
some of the strictest gun laws Chicago
the city has some of the strictest if
not the strictest in the entire country
can we get how many people were shot in
Chicago this weekend we haven't done
that in a while that's always a fun one
and they always are trying to take the
guns then from the good guys in Chicago
who want to be able to say protect their
house property family you know that sort
of crazy thing but what he talks about
there is not say let's go get the guns
because we have the gun laws it's that
there might be something else going on
here across our nation do you think it
might have something to do with mental
health you remember when that when that
crazy person shot up those 20 I think it
was 22 kids and a couple teachers in
Texas remember that a couple months ago
and then Joy Reid dare goes on her show
the next day and says it has nothing to
do with mental health as if an as if a
mentally healthy person could ever walk
into a school and do sort of that sort
of thing by the very definition by any
same definition of mental health of
course the person was not mentally
healthy 30 people were shot in Chicago
this weekend seven died seven died so
that's pretty average for Chicago but
what do we do with all of this what do
we do with all this as we watch them try
to censor you and we watch them try to
inject you and we watch them try to take
your gas stove and your gun well you
know what you have to do you have to go
on offense and you have to go on offense
early you have to find the root of the
problem and go after that and shocker
guys I got one that's going to knock you
out of your chair
that's what we're doing right here in
Florida so as you guys know wokism and
critical race Theory and this this
completely dishonest assessment of
History 1619 project that the United
States was founded on racism we are the
least racist nation in the history of
the world yes right now we are there is
no place with less racism than the
United States especially when you factor
in all of the people from all walks of
life who came here and it basically has
worked until these woke freaks have
decided to to burn it to the ground but
we ain't going to let them do it what do
you do what do you do when they're
importing all of these bad ideas well
earlier In that clip that we showed you
of Bill Maher he talks about it at the
college level right at the college level
they came in and they took these 18 year
old minds and they turned them from
being decent hopefully somewhat
productive members of society or at
least future productive members of
society and they turn them into mindless
woke robots but you got to get them
before College because now we know this
is leaking into literally kindergarten
and first grade with this gender
nonsense and confusing kids about what
sex they are and gender and all of that
nonsense so you know what's going on
right here in Florida will run DeSantis
uh is passing some laws passing some
laws not to stifles free speech but to
make sure that places of Education are
about education and not indoctrination
here he is talking about this AP
African-American history course that was
going to be pushed in the Florida
schools that he has made sure is not
going to get there not because he
doesn't want African-American history
taught or an honest assessment of this
of slavery but he does not want politics
and a dishonest assessment pushed on
every kid going through our school
system here in the State of Florida our
education standards not only don't
prevent but they require teaching black
history all the important things that's
part of our Core Curriculum this was a
separate course on top of that for
advanced placement credit and the issue
is we have guidelines and standards in
Florida we want education not
indoctrination if you fall on the side
of indoctrination we're going to decline
if it's education then we will do this
course so when I heard it didn't meet
the standards I figured yeah they may be
doing Syracuse it's way more than that
this course on black history what are
one what's one of the lessons about
queer Theory now who would say that an
important part of black history is queer
theory that is somebody pushing an
agenda on our kids and so when you look
to see they have stuff about
intersectionality abolishing prisons
that's a political agenda and so we're
on that's the wrong side of the line for
Florida standards we believe in teaching
kids facts and how to think but we don't
believe they should have an agenda
imposed on them when you try to use
black history to shoehorn in queer
Theory you are clearly trying to use
that for political purposes so they're
trying to push queer theory in
African-American AP courses here so you
go into this AAP class so you're in 11th
or 12th grade you think you're going to
learn about African-American history and
I believe we have American history but
of course we can look at moments that
are important to specific segments of
society they're really important to
everybody but we could obviously he as
de Santa said right up top we're not
we're not trying to not teach about
slavery or give an honest assessment of
history but you go into that class
thinking you're going to learn about say
slavery and next thing you know you find
out that Harriet Tubman was bi-curious
and the Underground Railroad
there's some other lesbian joke there
you get it guys you get it enough with
this enough it's enough
so what do you do you go on offense you
do exactly what Ron DeSantis is doing
you go early in so that we don't have to
uh deal with this at the college level
you don't have Minds that have been
obliterated going to colleges where then
these awful professors don't have to do
much to turn these kids into antifa you
know trans flag waving lunatics that is
what you do and then what else do you do
now really to link this thing to the top
what we need to fight for our
alternative platforms or renovate the
old ones now I don't know that the old
ones can be renovated I really don't
know that it can work I'm not even
totally convinced that what Elon can do
with Twitter will fully work I'm the
most bullish on that certainly and I
believe that Elon can do a lot of good
there and there are some good things
happening but Twitter is still very
weird right now and sometimes the
Machinery might just be so broken right
like I don't Facebook is not turning
around Facebook is the Titanic and the
the iceberg is there and there's nothing
they can do like they're going down and
they should go down YouTube is going
down and it should go down these things
cannot be manipulated that much because
they are such monstrosities but you can
create some other things uh and what you
can do though is what Elon is trying and
I do want to give him credit for this I
give him credit often but even though I
don't think it's doing everything good
at the moment as you know he's firing
people left and right and that's a good
start here's a little something from pen
magnet Thursday night it was a lightning
thunderstorm on Twitter the world's most
vocal social media Elon Musk fired
practically half of Twitter employees as
a result Twitter's total strength would
go from 3 000 oh would go to 3700 from 7
500. obviously that's a couple of months
ago when he took over but you have to
understand what he did was he went in
there he fired these people who were
mostly activists many of them were not
coming to work they were doing things
counter to what the the purpose of the
company is hopefully to make money and
provide a decent service that would be
the idea uh and why am I telling you
about this now because when when you
have these companies that have so much
power over us and then they get staffed
by the very people who have been taught
gender theory in a African-American
studies class and have been completely
Bamboozled by fake news and
misinformation that they were told is
the truth and all of those things you
get just a wild set of children at these
companies and it's crazy so you may have
seen some of these We we played one of
these once there are all of these videos
all over Tick Tock and I hope you're not
on Tick Tock I'm not on Tick Tock we do
have an official Ruben report Tick Tock
channel on a phone I said to my guys we
don't have to do this somebody decided
to put it on their phone and you're
probably watching right now and good
luck with all of that
um but on Tick Tock they put up all
these videos these Google employees
Facebook employees Twitter employees of
just their day they're just having a day
at work they're always drinking coffee
and doing these things so here is a
Google product manager Nicole Sai
showing what a day in her life as a
Google employee is and I think you'll
understand why we're showing you this a
day in my life working from the Google
LA office I always grab some candy from
the reception before heading in this
used to be an old aircraft Hangar so the
decorations hanging from the ceiling
kind of looks like an aircraft flying in
before it was a Google office this
aircraft Hangar belonged to Howard
Hughes so there's tons of memorabilia
next I'm going to pass by these art
installations they're a really good
photo op or you can sit in there and get
some work done I'm gonna head to the
coffee shop to grab some coffee and a
fruit cup since I missed breakfast and
then I'm heading over to this butterfly
themed room to take my first meeting and
I'm gonna head over to the confetti room
to take my next meeting it's so sparkly
and beautiful in here I love that a lot
of our rooms are themed then I'm gonna
grab my two favorite drinks which is
this green tea and coconut water next
I'm gonna go upstairs and grab some
lunch they always have pizza and a
variety of different vegetables and meat
the food is always really good and of
course everything you see in the office
is free on my way out of the cafe I ran
into a doogler which is a dog googler
and ran into some ghosts when they were
renovating the office there were a lot
of spooky stories from the crew so
there's a whole area in the office where
you can listen to them then I got more
work done and headed over to the massage
chairs to wrap up my day let me know
what you want to see next
as Connor just pointed out when is this
girl working
did work enter her thought during the
day and as Phoenix said we were watching
this you're 21 right 22. it's joking
you're 22. uh that he said he just said
this was everyone that I went to college
with he wisely dropped out of college
has a great gig over here uh but this
this affect this strange way that they
speak and as he said they all got A's in
high school and then they just go to
these places and then they basically
just become part of the machine but you
see this is one of the things that Elon
was complaining about when he walked in
there why did he fire half the workforce
because first off most of them were
working from home he said that they were
spending literally millions of dollars
on lunch and no one was even eating the
delicious food but you can see they've
created this very fake very uh what
would you call it like plastic world for
these people for these children they are
children who were ill-equipped to do
anything so it is very unclear to me I
don't want to make too much about this
girl but it's very unclear to me whether
she ever worked she played with the dog
she checked out Howard hughes's old
memorable Amelia she had coffee well
you're not going to believe this one
guys she had to make a video the other
day because yeah she got laid off a day
in my life getting laid off at Google so
I woke up to this really ominous text
from my boss and I honestly had no idea
what it was going to be about so I
called her the minute I woke up and saw
this and she told me to check the news
and my email so I rushed downstairs to
find out that I had lost access to
basically everything I couldn't log into
my email or even check my calendar I
called my boss back and we just sobbed
over the phone because she was also
finding out about my layoff for the
first time today too I started getting
calls from a bunch of my co-workers and
started finding out who else was let go
on my team and some neighboring teams as
well but I think the worst part is that
it seems like no one was consulted on
this decision and everyone was just
finding out about the layoffs at the
same time it just felt like a really bad
game of Russian Roulette and there was
no consistency around who was let go it
was also not Performance Based so it
just felt really random I opened up
LinkedIn which honestly was not great
for my mental health there were so many
people people who were in the same boat
that were both equally as shocked and
blindsided but it did help me feel a
little less alone honestly I spent so
much of the day crying that I just felt
so tired from being sad and wanted to do
something that would just make me feel
better luckily I have an annual pass so
I headed over to Disneyland because I
wanted to go eat my feelings so I
started off with a cinnamon Galaxy
churro and then went to the Teriyaki
Turkey Leg this is a special limited
edition item for the Lunar New Year
celebration at Disney California
Adventure I had some rice krispie a corn
dog did some drawing and even had
another churro I don't really know
what's next for me but I'll be vlogging
my journey and posting more content
about it so feel free to follow along
I really mean this guys this is
genuinely psychotic and again as Phoenix
just pointed out this is a ton of people
like I'm not just taking this random
girl this is what an entire industry has
been created of an entire generation of
young people the weird way she speaks
and who could eat all that the two
churros what else did she have she had
the Spanish Empanada and the whatever no
one could eat that much all right and of
course she does it at Disney like the
whole thing it's just incredible uh but
you know my friend David Sachs who who's
a brilliant Tech Guy uh uh SAS genius uh
he's been on the show from the all-in
podcast one of the things he often talks
about is how when you go into these
companies right so you you go into a
giant company and you start looking
around and what you see is that there
are a gajillion middle men who do
nothing so what Elon did and what I
think is now happening across the tech
world is they are going in and they're
firing all of these middle managers
these product managers like this Nicole
girl meaning you don't really do
anything all day you sit there with the
camera in your face drinking your fancy
latte but you're not actually doing work
who do they keep they keep the engineers
they keep the Architects right they keep
the people who are keeping the lights on
who are building the product but they're
getting rid of all of these people
and I love how she says nobody was
consulted we weren't even consulted when
we all got laid off like they were going
to sit down and be like guys you're all
doing jack we're getting radio like
that's in essence what they did they
just did it via a text or something but
this thing about like you know it's
ironic I guess at some level look I
talked to a camera for a living and you
guys know an awful lot about me and it
is what it is but this this like bizarre
obsession with the minutia of every
moment of your life and how many churros
you ate
I had two cheros yesterday I didn't make
a video about it
anyway the entire tech industry right
now is getting rid of people like this
and I think that is a sign for good
for the tech Giant's Global Workforce an
email more worrying than surprising we
hired for a different economic reality
than the one we face today the company's
chief executive told them announcing 12
000 jobs will go it's Workforce to
shrink by six percent the cuts spread
across regions it's Google's biggest
ever round of layoffs and yet it's a
common story in a sector that surged
through the pandemic Google's Workforce
pullback follows this week's Microsoft
announcement 10 000 jobs to go nearly
five percent of its Workforce Amazon has
cut 18
000 jobs and late last year Facebook's
parent meta shared 11 000 positions
that's 13 of its people still big but
for now big Tech is shrinking all right
this is good guys this is good the giant
top-down machine of big Tech that was
connected to government and connected to
the world economic Forum ideas and all
of these things it's starting to shrink
some of the useless people like that
girl are starting to go away and then if
you can get some good people in to own
the platforms and to really fight for
the right principles and return us to
the internet that maybe we all thought
we were getting on 20 years ago when we
were all getting on MySpace you know and
it was supposed to be this fun thing and
you could communicate with friends and
whatever it was before it became this
sensorious monster it's like that would
all be good so you have to build it
Twitter 2.0 Elon is doing that and as I
said I think there's some struggles
there but he's absolutely doing it you
have to do what we're doing with Rumble
and then you have to do it at a societal
level what's going on here in Florida we
have to rebuild what the the ethos what
the story what the purpose of the United
States was and that's exactly what we
are doing here and then you know what
happens as I often talk about it you do
the right thing if you fight for what's
right
the truth is
you can't stop it it's there and people
start recognizing it that's why the
other guys are always screaming really
that Al Gore clip of Al Gore you know
just ranting and raving about the oceans
boiling whatever he's emoting like that
because he's a liar and a buffoon so he
needs to up it this is what they've done
on TV and what the left has done with
almost everything why they're always
crying and they care about feelings more
than anything else because the facts and
the truth are against them but if you do
the right thing which is something that
Elon Musk did he did Against All Odds I
mean the entire machine tried to stop
him from buying Twitter he bought
Twitter and then you know what happened
we showed you this one this is from
about three weeks ago he goes to talk to
our military and and watch the reaction
to him and and just think how different
this would be if say this was I don't
know Bill Gates
Elon Musk
[Applause]
yeah so they appreciate it when you do
the right thing and this would be my
message we just got a couple more clips
for you to bring this thing home
Elon Musk is a disaffected liberal as he
said until this last election he had
never voted for a republican as far as
he could remember so he is mostly a
liberal now the media treats him like
he's a far-right maniac right and he has
said he's going to support Ron DeSantis
or at least wouldn't support Ron
DeSantis if he was to run
um but the other disaffected liberals
they've got to come around you either
have to vote the right way or fight a
little bit harder or something because
it's you it's you liberals that will
need a refuge right it really is so Bill
Maher once again man I'm trying with you
I'm trying with you I drank some tequila
for you on your on your birthday texted
you about it okay uh we need these
liberal positions to be adjusted or or
at least the Liberals behave a little
more liberally here's bill
it's all about that stuff well that's
all about identity it's all about being
queer or trans I mean children can't
understand that stuff not in
kindergarten most of these people who
are making the argument we're making are
liberal people who think it's a great
thing that an American now anybody can
actually be whatever they want and of
course trans is a real thing rare
but real but rare that part seems to be
like we all seem to have to pretend that
we're born
I don't know jump ball I don't know
and there are parents and I've seen it
in South Carolina even where they're
bragging about their children at four or
five or six transitioning I'm like what
are you talking about they haven't let
the natural uh process happen and I
think the Biden Administration is all in
on that all right so once again uh you
guys I know some of you get frustrated
when I play these more Clips because a
lot of you go yes Dave he gets it every
now and again a broken clock is right
twice a day okay fine fine
um but he isn't going to vote
Republicans and even there at the end he
blames Biden for some of this but he
obviously voted for Biden in the last
election so I mean this with love and
respect I'm going to keep working on you
bill because there is an off ramp for
you and the people like you and that off
ramp is a place like Florida that off
ramp is other Tech that off ramp is not
voting for Democrats anymore and I think
what will go down because I think I'm
going to be right at the more time goes
on what will go down is one of my
proudest moments on camera ever was when
I was on Bill Maher's podcast and I
basically got him to admit that even a
guy like him a lifelong Lefty Hollywood
liberal could move to Florida if
gets worse in communist California
if California yeah says I have to take
shots
and DeSantis says I don't
hello Florida
that's what I'll say about DeSantis
he's a good dude he's a good dude
he really is and he doesn't care whether
you smoke weed and he doesn't care who
you marry just he doesn't but to sound
like the uh
voiceover and a movie that's coming out
soon
just got real
but like for me personally really
just got real with that yeah and that's
that's in my mind I left this place
because of it so that's the interesting
part it's like everyone has their
threshold everyone has their moment
where gets real right everyone has
their moment for him it's when they come
after his body now now he doesn't have
kids so maybe he can tolerate the stuff
that he's allowing to be voted in in Los
Angeles where he lives and in California
more broadly and across America because
he doesn't because he intellectually he
doesn't like the woke stuff and he
doesn't want boys turning into girls and
he doesn't want you know a bunch of
white kids hating themselves because of
the color of their skin uh but but he
doesn't have that much skin in that game
this the game that he does have skin in
and I actually don't mean this in a
judgmental way but his skin is in his
life right and when they come to inject
him one more time uh you know he may not
care that much about gun laws because
he's rich and has a certain set of
security that the average person doesn't
have and I think that's connected to the
overall overarching sort of mental state
of the Liberals there are positions
these days and again I wrote a book
defending Classical liberalism right I
did don't burn this book it's pretty
solid
um
but liberals have failed liberalism
there might be a reason for that and I'm
just going to keep working on these
people but I think you see we must build
all new things and guess what it's
happening at a government level we're at
a societal level here in Florida and
it's not it's not just Florida by the
way there's a lot of good things
happening in Iowa and Arkansas and Texas
and Tennessee and South Dakota and many
other red States but we have to do it at
a technological level that's going on
with Rumble and locals you have to do it
in your own Community you really do like
like if you whatever it might be if your
local grocer
literally your local like local grocery
store if they've got all the signs
outside about trans lives matter and we
hate nobody except everybody or whatever
their heat whatever their signs say it's
like don't go there drive a little bit
further to go elsewhere don't force them
to close or anything like that right it
would be it would be a sort of offshoot
version of the the gay Baker or the the
cake story it's like I didn't want to
force the baker to bake the cake you can
get a cake elsewhere you can get a cake
delivered use your freedom to either
move if you don't like that Community or
build a better product or become a cake
baker or whatever you want to do that is
my message to you on this Tuesday if you
have not subscribed and I have not made
my point clear today I don't know what
to tell you please go to rumble.com
hopefully you're watching on Rumble
right now rumble.com reubenreport and
subscribe right there we got a post game
show coming up momentarily at
reubenreport.locals.com part one of my
interview with former head of the CIA
former Secretary of State Mike Pompeo is
up right now we leave you I apologize in
advance with Kamala Harris and I will
see you in about 52 seconds
[Music]